[Música]
buenas noches primero quiero hacer unas
advertencias advertencia número uno que
las imágenes que utilizó la presentación
o son mías las he tomado yo o las he
tomado como un recurso abierto y respeto
los derechos de autor eso es lo primero
o son de la comisión de regulación de
comunicaciones
la segunda advertencia es que lo que
busco con mi presentación es provocar no
es una conclusión ni siquiera podría
decir que son mis puntos de vista porque
seguramente a veces pienso adelante a
veces pienso atrás pero creo que todo es
válido entonces lo que quiero es
provocarle si quiero que después de mi
intervención no hagan preguntas sino que
critiquen que participen botero espero
tu participación y la tercera y última
advertencia es que esta presentación que
he denominado del equilibrio al caos
hablando entre la aparente balanza o
equilibrio que existe entre derecho de
autor y el consumo de contenidos se ha
dicho de paso entre autor y consumidor
no lo hago ni como regulador ni como
política pública ni como profesor ni
como investigador ni como nada lo hago
como un creador porque realmente para
armar esta charla me quise poner el
traje de lo que fue alguna vez un sueño
que tuve y era vivir o como productor o
como escritor o como artista y pensar
que de ese contenido podía cobrar unas
regalías y de allí con el copyright
hacerme de pronto rico y famoso como
shakira o como carlos vives y resulta
que entonces prometo
tres blogs una página web hasta un
cortometraje tres libros artículos
científicos pero por ningún lado fue
pero resulta que todo ese contenido que
está abierto hoy y de acceso libre para
todos ha hecho y ha desarrollado una
forma de pensar diferente me y es lo que
me permite hoy poder hablarles de
derecho de autor y poder hablarle de lo
que creo que ha sido un aparente
equilibrio equilibrio durante siglos
pero qué
se encuentra en un caos
cuando hablo de equilibrio sin duda
hablo porque creo que esta imagen debe
ser diferente para todos durante
muchísimos siglos y como ya lo decía mi
antecesora en esa intervención que contó
desde la era de guttenberg y de iu del
primer régimen en 1710 de la reina ana
que creó el primer régimen de propiedad
intelectual todo funcionó durante
trescientos años igual un autor con su
casete con su lp con su cd o un cineasta
con su distribución en un cine o en la
televisión o en cualquier otra forma de
distribución distinta internet y pues un
escritor con sus libros recibía de una
manera lineal es casi como de innovación
lineal una remuneración a través de una
boleta a través de la compra en una
tienda de discos oa través de la compra
de una librería cierto y ese era el
modelo lineal y eso aparentemente es una
balanza una balanza que durante siglos
trató de mantenerse y que era simple y
sencilla de entender
apareció internet creo que hacia 1996
empezó a hablar de que llegó internet ya
esto nos va a desequilibrar un poco la
balanza
este señor es guttenberg este señor fue
él el precursor de la imprenta y como le
decía natalia el precursor de de que
pese a empezar a generarse copias y
empezáramos a hablar de derechos para
los autores para los editores y aquella
fotografía que está libre en internet y
que espero que la reina no venga
exigirme copyright pero le tome su
primer su primera no su primera ley de
1.710 que era el primer régimen de
propiedad intelectual y como ya lo
decían aquí ese es un régimen que se fue
haciendo durante trescientos años cada
vez más fuerte porque empezó siendo la
protección de 14 años de 17 años en vida
para poder reclamar los derechos por un
por una por una producción o por una
obra y se fue convirtiendo a lo que es
hoy en colombia la vida del autor más 80
años cierto y eso cada vez más duro y
ese es el régimen de derecho de autor
que todos conocemos pero llegamos al
caos apareció internet y apareció
internet de banda ancha y eso es una
foto de black friday que está
y que es con derecho libre y que se
define el caos en la real academia en la
lengua el diccionario de la real
academia la lengua como ese
comportamiento errático e impredecible
que puede suceder y cambiar las
estructuras como la balanza que les
mostraba al principio entre el autor y
el consumidor y entonces yo quise
traerle eso hoy en esta charla lo que
para mí está generando el caos en el
derecho de autor que todos conocemos y
que todos concebimos pero debo hacer una
advertencia no quiero decir con caos
para mi creencia personal solamente en
algo malo yo creo que hay un caos
positivo lo dijo
schumpeter cuando cuando definió
innovación como ese proceso de
destrucción creativa entonces yo creo
que él se caos es una oportunidad de
reconstruir y de rehacer la política y
de rehacer la normatividad y la
estructura de la protección del derecho
de autor y creo que hoy ha quedado claro
en las distintas intervenciones que
hemos tenido entonces esto sí es de
opinión personal si bien habló de caos
no lo vean solo como algo negativo sino
como algo que nos debe llevar a crear y
a innovar
primer elemento del caos ya yo no solo
ubicó un consumidor y un autor en la
balanza sino que tengo múltiples actores
este es la famosa convergencia
operadores plataformas creadores
audiovisuales los de contenidos
operadores fabricantes de tecnología es
decir poder ubicar el derecho de autor
que tiene cada uno de esos elementos y
más que esto solo lo que ocupo en la
presentación es cada vez más difícil y
ese es el primer elemento un modelo
común acción internet que es
multistakeholder o de múltiples
interesadas que los que han hecho que
este mercado de internet se desarrolle
cosa muy distinta a lo que fue el origen
de la creación de cualquier otra
creación que era simplemente una autoría
alguien que pagaba por acceder a ese
conocimiento pero adicionalmente las
principales plataformas donde convergen
hoy productores y consumidores han
creado una nueva categoría que son los
prosumidores y qué problema porque si
tengo una balanza donde en un lado está
el autor y en el otro el consumidor pero
resulta que es que las plataformas que
más crecen en usuarios
tú qué es facebook es instagram pues el
que publica el contenido el dueño del
contenido es el mismo que lo consume y
entonces todos somos productores y
consumidores la balanza empieza a
generar es una descalificación un
desequilibrio que es necesario repensar
y por ende definir nuevas estructuras y
eso fue un estudio que hicimos en la crc
donde encontramos que en el desarrollo
de la economía digital hoy todos los
sectores de la economía han tenido una
transformación han tenido un impacto y
si vemos el círculo más grande vemos que
son todas las industria y todos los
sectores de la economía y si vemos el
que sigue el amarillo vemos que es que
todos a todos les ha parecido una
competencia y esa competencia es 100%
digital pero si nos vamos si no si nos
podemos saber uno a uno vemos que la
industria de contenidos se ha prensa se
ha canales de televisión se ha educación
investigaciones tiene que ver con el
contenido entonces todas sin duda alguna
han tenido un impacto directo con
internet y porque esto es importante
porque estamos en la era de las
nuevas tecnologías de la inteligencia
artificial de la analítica de datos y
ahora vamos a ver cómo ese 5g es que
promete tener mejores velocidades esa
hiperconectividad que va a ser muy
importante para el desarrollo de la
industria va a tener un impacto
definitivo en la industria de contenidos
otro elemento que le nace a ese caos las
sociedades de gestión colectiva y aquí
lo hemos dicho y no quise hablar con
ejemplos propios de colombia porque me
puedo meter en problemas pero trajo un
ejemplo de un municipio de un pueblo de
españa que se llama montejo donde con
este letrero que ustedes ven aquí todos
los panaderos tenderos hoteleros
pasteleros se unieron para evitar que
las distintas sociedades de gestión
colectiva es gallega y águeda llegaran a
cobrarle derechos de autor y entonces
solamente pudieron distribuir música con
licencia escribir commons copyleft color
ius etcétera o de producción de dominio
público y de esta forma todo un pueblo
le cerró la puerta a la sociedad de
gestión colectiva porque porque algo
está pasando y definitivamente la
estructura
no es la que la que debería ser en este
mundo digital
y claro copiad malditos no es un consejo
sino una página www copiad malditos
punto net donde pueden descargar un
documental que es bastante interesante
de lo que le puede costar a un pastelero
pagarle a uno dos tres cuatro cinco seis
siete ocho sociedades de gestión
colectiva por poder escuchar algo de
música o poder tener acceso a alguna
imagen audiovisual y esto es
definitivamente la experiencia que
sucedió en ese municipio y sin duda hoy
muchísimas de las de las empresas y
proveedores de redes y servicios de
comunicaciones audiovisuales tocaban
nuestra puerta en la comisión de
regulación y nos dicen por favor me va a
tocar subir las tarifas a los usuarios
porque el costo eficiente de mi servicio
no da con tantos derechos que tengo que
pagar además del productor además del
realizador del director de los actores
que están muy bien y tienen su derecho
pues me toca pagar a la sociedad gestión
colectiva es un problema lo es y está
generando caos otro caos son los
ciudadanos sin duda el consumidor como
tal esta imagen que seguramente lo han
visto antes porque son imágenes de un
estudio de una firma que se llama o un
muestra
el tráfico de internet pues el ciudadano
sólo quiere ver vídeos y sólo quiere
maratón e ar y no le importa nada no le
importa ni el derecho de autor
simplemente quiere ver más y más y más
vídeos y no el vídeo pues son juegos si
no son música en general industria de
contenidos
y si vemos en colombia por ejemplo cómo
es el consumo de plataformas o test
audiovisuales que nos encontramos que si
bien todavía no hay una sustitución de
ese mercado sin duda alguna está
creciendo el consumo de plataformas y
vamos a ver cómo reaccionamos ante la
proliferación de plataformas que vendrán
en los próximos meses con tantas nuevas
plataformas de disney de apel etcétera
pero lo que vemos es que el 15% de
nuestros hogares ya empieza a pagar
también a plataformas porque solo quiere
ver
y el problema no es el problema es que
como lo he manifestado en otras
ocasiones existe un gran riesgo que pasa
como pasó con los sms y es que es el
fenómeno del core koetting sustituya
totalmente el servicio de televisión que
todos conocemos como pasó con la
mensajería donde hoy pues mandamos
mensajes en whatsapp pero ya no en sms y
eso lo pudimos demostrar a través de un
estudio pero hay otro problema de ese
mismo usuario consumidor y es que no es
un verdadero ciudadano digital y resulta
que my ribble profesor de la
universidade los de kansas en eeuu
propuso los nueve ejes de la ciudadanía
digital dos de ellos el conocimiento que
debe tener el ciudadano en derechos y
deberes digitales y haya leyes digitales
lo conocen hoy no entonces efectivamente
y es una realidad si hay una violación
permanente y constante de los derechos
de autor bueno o malo no lo sé pero que
es una violación de lo que hoy existe y
es considerado como el derecho de autor
es una violación
y hay nuevos modelos de negocio otra
otra otra pata que le sale al gato otro
elemento para el caos todos conocen a la
tigresa del oriente' cierto la tigresa
del oriente' muy famosa por música pero
no vende un disco
no vendo un disco su modelo de negocio
es otro es ser un personaje cierto su
modelo de negocio
ese es hacer shows es presentar
conciertos con su maravillosa música
celestial y tener 17 millones de views
pero nunca vender un disco
entonces el modelo de negocio si ha
cambiado
y aparecen los youtubers y debo decir
que para no usar el violarle el derecho
autor a ningún youtuber no hubo forma de
encontrar a alguien que motorizará usar
su canal pues use el mío
lastimosamente sólo tengo 149
suscriptores todavía no soy
suficientemente influencer pero si hay
muchos que quieren serlo todo el tiempo
y ahí vienen tres preguntas uno conocen
los términos y condiciones del uso de
esas plataformas qué imágenes se
utilizan cuando desarrollas un vídeo qué
música usas cuando cuando subes un vídeo
y eso hace parte precisamente de ese
caos que existe y que está
desequilibrando la balanza de lo que
conocíamos como derecho de autor y algo
mencionaron en ese auditorio ciencia
tecnología e innovación
las universidades sustentan hoy su
política de calidad educativa en cuanto
público donde público en el primer
cuartil de revistas de investigación
donde generalmente tengo que pagar y
tengo que invertir para que puedan
leerme los científicos y me puedan citar
los científicos e investigadores más
famosos pero resulta que hoy hay una
gran editorial tiene un
en pleito con esta plataforma es hijo
que cogió el robo los 68 millones de
artículos que existía en estas revistas
y los hizo públicos a través de esta
plataforma entonces surge una nueva
lucha la lucha de las plataformas de
acceso abierto a conocimiento versus las
que cobran por el acceso al conocimiento
y eso es otro elemento que le nace al
caos bueno o malo cada uno tendrá su
opinión lo cierto es que es un elemento
que cambió totalmente la estructura del
derecho de autor y aquí sí viene algo
que me dejó totalmente descolocado y son
las nuevas tecnologías y ya lo había
anticipado la casa christie vendió este
cuadro por 6 millones de dólares pero el
cuadro no lo hizo ningún artista lo hizo
la inteligencia artificial y entonces
ahí si llegamos a la entraña del derecho
de autor y se me desnaturaliza
totalmente los elementos del derecho de
autor creación de una persona a partir
de su inteligencia y su originalidad y
entonces ese ser humano aquí no está
presente o de pronto estuvo presente
cuando programó el sistema y programó
lápiz etc
pero lo cierto es que así como hacen
cuadros se hacen películas se hacen
libros se hacen audios y eso
definitivamente desequilibró totalmente
esa balanza
hay un destello de luz para mí
el destello de luz no es suficiente no
está aún la luz pero la unióneuropea
saca una directiva y dice las
plataformas deben empezar a cuidar ya
verificar que el derecho de autor no se
ha vulnerado y se discute hoy si también
las empresas que sí son reguladas por
una como la por la comisión de
comunicaciones que son los proveedores
de redes se pregunta si lo que transita
por sus canales también debería ser
regulado y responsabilizar a las
plataformas no solamente sino también a
los proveedores de redes por el la
violación al derecho de autor o no pero
esas son las discusiones que están hoy y
la nueva ley de derechos de autor
también plantea que pueden ejercerse
medidas tecnológicas para perseguir la
violación a derechos de autor y hoy eso
está en la regulación de colombia es lo
que necesitamos es lo suficiente no lo
sabemos no no tenemos la evidencia
suficiente hoy para ver si este es el
método lo cierto es que tenemos que
construirlo entre todos para reflexionar
definitivamente existe hoy un
desequilibrio en esa balanza de derechos
de autor que todos conocemos
evidente que hay una violación
permanente de derechos de autor bien por
desconocimiento por parte del ciudadano
o bien porque lo hacemos con dolo o con
culpa o bien porque definitivamente
queremos promover el acceso abierto al
conocimiento y ahí ya no habría
violación al derecho de autor es claro
que con el pasar del tiempo existe una
dificultad de competir en esta industria
de contenidos y por ende los nuevos
modelos de negocios se hacen necesarios
la regulación se va transformando pero
tímidamente no podemos decir que hoy
existen y conocemos un país que tenga la
regulación que necesitamos y este caos
desequilibra la balanza y esa balanza
hay que equilibrar la por eso me atrevo
me atrevo esos son mis atrevimientos
primero creo que el mercado único
digital va a ser la solución en los
próximos años creo que si bien hoy
tenemos el regulador por ejemplo en
colombia que necesitamos para la
realidad que vivimos en 10 años
necesitamos 1 cuna a todo derechos de
autor regulación de proveedores de redes
y servicios de comunicaciones
competencia etcétera un único regulador
y eso es una discusión que se está dando
reguladores como off com en reino unido
lo discuten hoy nosotros ya tenemos un
regulador único pero no suficiente y
esto es necesario pero va a ser
necesario en el futuro cuando toda esta
industria se termine de desarrollar
cuando el problema sea un poco más un
poco más evidente y ello conlleva que
ser un mercado único digital regulación
enmarcada en las 5 g pero no en las 5 g
de conectividad sino en lo que la wii te
dice 5 g de regulación con regulación
auto regulación regulación colaborativa
simplificación repensar los modelos de
negocio formar ciudadanos competencias
que deben tener repensar la estructura
de gestión de los derechos de autor cuál
es el nuevo rol de la sociedad de
gestión colectiva puede gestionar los
derechos de la inteligencia artificial
es una pregunta bastante interesante y
finalmente lo que ya había dicho hace un
rato en este auditorio fortalecer el
esquema multistakeholder esto no es
decisión sólo del gobierno ni siquiera
del estado los reguladores
independientes es una decisión de todos
porque en internet todos somos
responsables de equilibrar la balanza
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]